Aspen is on Facebook and we have a
Facebook group called the Ramsey
baby-steps community over 100 over a
hundred thousand folks hanging out with
us be sure you check it out
Dave I'm just now beginning my baby
steps at 19 years old I'm really nervous
but I think I can do it you have any
advice on getting a cheap car or ways to
save money on a car absolutely
absolutely you are looking for what's
called a garage sale car a garage sale
car is a car that is ugly it's ugly but
it has great mechanical condition it was
driven 25 years ago by a little old lady
back and forth to church she's died and
her family is having a garage sale and
the car is old the seats are split
because they've been sitting in the
garage the paint is faded and it's a bad
station wagon from a bad movie of
yesteryear but it's in perfect condition
mechanically because it's just been
sitting there in her garage it's got
20,000 miles on it it's 15-20 years old
and you buy that car for five hundred
bucks because it's not got any value on
the market but it's got a lot of life
left in her and you have to give her a
name because the car like that deserves
a name this is old blue big red the
Hoopoe wagon I don't know you give her a
name but you got it if you you have to
give cars like that a name
I had a friend working here a while back
we've told this story 100 times this is
a few years back but it actually
happened and I had dropped my car at the
shop and he decided I said hey take me
to the shop and drop me off and get my
car and he pulls up and he goes I hope
you don't mind riding in big red and I'm
like no tell me about big red so big red
was a 1994 Granada land yacht right I
mean this thing was unbelievable and it
was originally red but it had faded the
pink and it originally
one of those vinyl tops on it vinyl roof
on it and it had peeled so big red had
whiskers kind of on the top but big red
was my buddy that works here's a great
aunt's car and it had 14,000 actual
miles on it and it looked like crap but
14,000 actual miles and he bought it
from the estate for five hundred bucks
and he drove big red for about two years
big red was a great car great car to get
started in now I don't know how broke
you are or how far down the rabbit hole
you've got to go on picking out your car
maybe it doesn't have to be quite as bad
as a big red but you are not looking for
a sex symbol in a car you are looking
for mechanical reliability and that's
how you start with a good hoopty and you
get you know that's a thousand dollar
car a 500 ollar car and it's got a lot
of life left in her you give her a name
and you drive her a little while and you
pile up cash and then you move up to a
$5,000 car that you pay cash for instead
of taking on $500 a month car payments
put $500 a month away for ten months
voila you'll have $5,000 it's magical
how that happens 10 whole months that
you'll drive your version of big red or
the Blue Goose
or the whatever whatever it is you want
to name this puppy but be sure you take
pictures of it because you got to tell
this story to your grandkids later yeah
I tell them this is what we did back in
the day we walked uphill both ways in
the snow to school you know I mean it's
without shoes and I mean all the grandpa
stories you got to have good grandpa
stories later and you gotta have good
pictures of big red I got pictures of
our version of big red and that the
Ramseys drove Oh
bad stuff bad stuff the one I didn't get
a picture I wasn't gonna tell the story
about the guy loaned me and I drove it
for three months
when we went broke it's a 1978 Cadillac
with 423,000 actual miles on it and it
was a piece of garbage and I drove that
car for 10 years one three month period
it felt like forever it was so
embarrassing
predominant color on it was bondo but
that's how we started back after we went
broke as we were on borrowing money
anymore
and we just saved a car payment and
saved a car payment and we went and
bought a thousand dollar car a one
thousand dollar car which was a sizable
upgrade from my friends loaner and I
took my friends precious little owner
back to him but it was a blessing I'm
not complaining it was a blessing at the
time does it beat walking and I wasn't
borrowing money and I saved a car
payment I saved $1,000 really really
fast and got out of that thing that
bondo buggy and but hey that's what you
do man you just think different but you
know the problem with most people is is
they buy cars to impress other people
I've got some really nice cars now and
none of them are for you they're for me
my need to impress you is zero i buy a
really nice vehicle because I'm a car
nut I love cars and I can afford it now
because I used to drive the bondo buggy
and that put me in a position that I can
afford it and that's what you do you
drive like no one else so then later you
can drive like no one else
a brand new car does not need to be
purchased by any of you until you have
at least a 1 million dollar net worth
you cannot afford to take the hit they
lose 70% of their value in the first 4
years turns a $30,000 car into a $10,000
car in four years and every time you
turn 30,000 in a 10,000 you better have
some extra coin laying around because
you're destroying your net worth and
when your whole net worth these things
are going down in value that's known as
stupid I've been stupid so I know what
stupid looks like
I used to tell me I got a PhD in D um B
so stay out of new cars stay out of car
payments buy something used by a garage
sale car if you're starting fresh or
you're starting over get you get you
something and give it a name get you
something get you a good hoop deep
that's how this works
then you're gonna win